what you are watching is a flailing
presidency
the best shot they have right now to to
stop the bleeding in the midterms is ram
their supreme court justice through that
seems like they actually will get that
and then make a bunch of pie in the sky
promises to get people not even that
people will believe but just distract
them from all of the carnage and misery
that everyone is seeing
around them
one of the
new flailing initiatives from joe biden
is more gun control
and and even this he's screwing up this
is usually a reliable
base democrat issue
doesn't appeal to the majority of
americans but it does appeal to the
democrat base and they're just trying to
keep them happy enough
but but even that biden screwed up biden
made the claim during a press conference
on guns
that a glock
is a weapon of war
you know
the future is cut short by a man with a
stolen glock
with 40 rounds a magazine with 40 rounds
and
it's really a weapon of war
it's really a weapon of war
now to be fair to joe biden he's not
just saying that the glock itself one of
the most common handguns if not the most
common handgun in america he's not just
saying that's a weapon of war
if a glock is a weapon of war then every
gun is a weapon of war
he's saying that the glock with the
magazine that holds a lot of rounds
that's what makes it a weapon of war
but
but then that just means that every gun
is a weapon of war because every gun
potentially
almost every gun potentially could have
a big magazine in it
right you just just swap out the
magazine
so so what biden is claiming is that
weapons of war are bad
we need to ban weapons of war
and every single gun can be a weapon of
war
does not take socrates to put that
together and say oh he wants to ban
all of the guns
i don't think that's going to play very
well either i do think that gun control
can work for democrats sometimes but not
not not this way this is but again it's
just appealing to the base because he's
already lost the middle he's already
lost
the
relative centrists
so now he's he's he is losing his base
right now he's ju he's got to try to get
the base back first then he can try to
rebuild the coalition he just doesn't
seem to have enough time now you say oh
yeah we're gonna ban all the guns he's
basically become beto hell yeah hell
yeah we're gonna ban your clocks
hey
come on man
did you like that clip i'm glad ring the
bell please that way you'll get
notifications and then because sometimes
you don't get notifications head on over
to apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio podcast
subscribe to the michael knowles show
leave a five star review we will see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you